alors ça c'est des légions d'imbéciles
or ça ça m'a énervé toute la journée je
vous le disais hier dans le gogo si pour
vous parler de gad elmaleh qui sera le
prochain invité d'une ambition intime
avec karine le marchand
et c'est vrai qu'ils avaient l'air de
bien s'entendre sur la bande annonce
bien sûr on n'a jamais dit qu'il est
temps sont ils sont super pote c'est ce
qu'ont à dire
visiblement karine le marchand n'a pas
trop kiffé le débat j'ai à vous dire
dans un instant ce cas-là postis
d'après-midi sur les réseaux sociaux
mais d'abord on regarde ce que vous avez
dit kelly et mathieu et je vous dis
qu'on voyait il ya un truc vois ça je
vous le dis tout le temps que les jets
là c'était extrêmement sympathique
franchement je vois pas où est le mal et
karine voilà elle est montée dans les
tours
je vais lui répondre dans un instant
assez planté et elle va se planter aussi
ça s'appelle fréquence par auxerre à
marcher avec ses fréquences temps on
s'en fout la paix et du bug ça va
marcher donc plus moi je tiens on peut
parler un petit peu d'amour sur ce
plateau parce que c'est là on parlait
pas de ça on passe de l'or alors
attachement voulait parler comme vous et
moi je voulais vous dire que juste une
chose cabernet ce n'est pas sa came
c'est sûr d'accord c'est sûr à 100% el
alem les choses passionnel le les gens
ce sulfureux
il est trop propre il est beaucoup trop
lisse il a les yeux bleus il à la police
[Musique]
c'est mon frère génomique ça n'ira pas
mais manu je crois que c'est miss à
l'habitude un mail à versailles alors
karine le marchand
je n'ai d'ailleurs je vais te dire ça
répond s'il vous plaît je veux dire ça
répond presque juste avant ça justement
salle j'ai dit son émission est super il
faudra faire quelques numéros seulement
parce qu'elle a sur lui une super
émission pour l'accueil dès lors on a
toujours été très sympathique et
conneries sur vidas et l'a26 la chiche
pascal doit tenir buzz en ce moment
karine le marchand
les réseaux sociaux ont donné le droit à
la parole à des légions d'imbéciles qui
avant de parler qu'au bar après un verre
de vin et ne causer aucun tort à la fed
activity ch pour les faisait taire tout
de suite alors qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
même ils ont le même droit de parole
qu'un prix nobel c'est l'invasion des
imbéciles alors traité d'imbécile que
des lives et dvd matthieu delormeau
pour les connaître un petit peu karine
et pour connaître un peu ils sont
beaucoup plus intelligent que toi
déjà je te le dis voilà que voilà donc
moi je prends toujours est toujours la
défense de mes chroniqueurs déjà je
trouve que c'est complètement démesuré
ta réponse voilà de dire que c'est des
imbéciles alors qu'ils ont rien dit sur
toi quels items depuis des années elle
tu adores elle te défends toujours là
elle donnait juste une analyse et puis
tu vois pas ne t'a pas insulter l ap
insulté par famille elle a rien dit
allez j'y allais 10 jusqu'à d'après lt
mais les bad boys c'est pas une insulte
voilà matthieu delormeau il a dit que
ton émission était très bien mais que
ambitions intime fallon faire peu pour
que ça marche
et derrière je sais pas ce que tu as je
pense qu'il faut que tu prennes une
camomille un peu dans les prés un sens
l'amour est dans le pré tout seul que tu
marches un peu dans le pré ce que tu te
retrouve un peu et quand tu seras talent
mais quand tu auras dégonfler voilà je
te le dis tu viendras nous voient sans
aucun problème pour l'instant c'est
vraiment je pense que c'est démesuré et
je trouve que ça a été très méchant ta
réponse bas mais je pense que ça a
beaucoup blessé mathieu et kelly kelly
franchement j'ai été très blessée parce
que j'ai toujours été fan d'elle et
j'adore ces émissions et je les ai
toujours dit et je suis un peu touché au
même la soutenons mais c'est normal
c'est très méprisant caricature c'est
gratuit c'est méchant c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on veut faire ici ou ici on n'est
jamais méchant et on n'aura jamais
méchants on veut rigoler jeux sont à
donner son avis on n'a jamais dit que
c'était des quintés je dirais mais les
bad boys alors gagné compense pour elle
c'est beau ça compense le droit d'avoir
de la télé chez l épreuve de regarder
[Applaudissements]
demain concert vraiment aidé acta est
aujourd'hui d'avoir gravi mais c'est
tout à fait ça elle veut pas qu'on pense
qu'on est là on rigole on redonne avec
les gens qui nous regardent ont besoin
de se distraire le soir on va pas
arriver là parler de politique de
truction on essaie de tourner ça à la
rigolade l'aldi les réseaux sociaux
s'étaient pas sur un réseau social
c'était là déjà et elle suit les gens
des réseaux sociaux est allé sur un
stage sur les réseaux sociaux
moi j'ai envie d'y renoncer la semaine
scène en parlant je vais dire légende et
d'instinct elles vous ont insultés
regardez bien de mettre ça c'est vous
quelle insulte alors alors aboli de
situations double berthod et couple on
s'en fout voilà c'est franchement c'est
ainsi qu'ils aient causé le frère de
jean mermoz
oui alors j'espère ce plateau justement
on rigole et tout ça il aurait fallu
qu'à répondre avec humour vida nature
est beaucoup mieux passé je dis rien
quand je pense que vous avez voulu me
caser avec elle je lui lécher les pieds
avec matin le traitent d'imbécile
bah merci n'était pas vrai mais c'est
vrai et je le dis à tout le monde vous
pouvez critiquer les chroniqueurs je
serai toujours de leur côté et je les
défendrai toujours et que vous ne croyez
pas quand vous critiquez les
chroniqueurs vous vous m'attaquez aussi
parce que je sais qu'il y en a qui ont
pas voilà le courage de dire les choses
de me dire les choses directement qu'ils
disent oui mais c'est les chroniqueurs
sachez que les chroniqueurs et moi c'est
la même pas c'est pareil voilà je vous
dis donc si vous critiquez un
chroniqueur vont critique également tu
vois là deux salles deux ambiances cave
adams ont fait laval quand tu te mets là
c'est étonnant d'abord merci beaucoup
pour la défense de nos devoirs et avec
autant de 2,2 de ba2 de sincérité river
après après je crois pour prendre sa
défense à l aller j'avais partie de ces
gens à mon avis qui n'ont pas regardé
l'émission c'est ce que vous effectuerez
un con way pour vous dire t'as vu ce
qu'ils ont dit deux choses à se raconter
un truc dans les airs il sera consulté
des amis s'ils avaient vu une émission
bien sortie de faire un truc de marquer
un truc aussi méchant alors que kelly
était toute mignonne en dix ans les
mêmes bad boys et les jolies et moi j'y
lis une émission et hop
ok encore deux trois conquis lui en dix
ans tout ce que je donnerais comme
message c'est regardent la télévision et
puis après tu commentes qu'est-ce que
vincent
j'étais carrément me cherche pas dans ce
qu'est ce qu'il valait mieux qu'à
tradition voilà et qu'elle fera des
excuses at elle menacé a battu sa gamme
voilà elle est marquée sur instagram et
nico rosberg lui réponde aux marques et
marques et commentaires bloqué parce
qu'on ne peut même pas lui répondre
on essaie à la chaîne hilton blocked on
espère qu'elle aura voilà le bel achat
non mais voilà elle et elle est
peut-être nerveuse en ce moment elle a
fait ça arrive à tout le monde
voilà voilà on va en parler d'autres
erreurs qui ont été faites d'ailleurs
dans un incident mais pour le moment
karine lemarchand voilà elle sera la
bienvenue quand elle se sera excusé et
bien entendu pour l'instant elle est
blacklisté de toutes nos émissions bien
entendu